les d'air que non loin de réquista dans
l'aveyron pourrait bien devenir un
royaume ludique c'est là en effet camp
hollandais monsieur van der bruggen a
conçu un jeu de construction basés sur
l' équilibre de pièces en bois un
procédé inédit qui déjà rencontre un
grand succès auprès des petits mais
aussi des grands il garrec et daniel
blaise ne me démentiront pas
il était une fois dans la vallée du tarn
aveyron une maison en ruine lanta passé
tout droit sorti de quelques contes
d'andersen
tom van der bruggen marchand de tableaux
à l'ail et du pilier de la peau comme
azuré de ses propres mains la
transformant ce petit château dont dix
fils à demeure à partir de l'âge de 10
ans j'ai voulu toujours faire et habité
le château
je suis un grand enfant né qui joue tous
les jours de ce rallye de ce principe
est né le jeu de construction kapla
capela comme cavender plan religieuse à
hollandais les planches est de lutter
rien d'extraordinaire à première vue
dans ces petits morceaux de pin des
landes pour les charges et de magie tom
la pile et dans le creuset de son
imagination
un certain nombre de considérations
mathématiques la longueur égale 2 5 fois
la largeur la largeur égale de trois
fois l'épaisseur ces trois premiers
chiffres impairs et entassés zones et
d'une paix ces deux philosophies ses
deux reins qui créent de tous
c'est un compromis idéal entre les
qualités sculpturale et les qualités
constructive parce qu'il ne peut pas y
avance culture sans construction il faut
que cela tienne on a trop peu insister
sur le monde imaginaire dans le jeu
d'enfant et en art jusque trop
précisément en volume
rapetti c'est les choses grandes
par exemple une être humain ça devient
une petite poupée une grande voiture ça
devient un petit modèle de voiture mais
exact on n'a pas laissé donc en bâtiment
on a voulu réduire les pierres de taille
ou les briques quelque chose d'existant
du bâtiment hors des enfants ont besoin
du monde imaginaire qui soit tout autre
chose et que ont créé dans l'espace
quelque chose de totalement libre et de
nouveau les planchettes kapla permettent
des constructions très élaboré tom
répète en ce moment le grand numéro
qu'il fera au salon international du
jouet à villepinte du 28 janvier au 3
février prochain la ville de paris lui a
par ailleurs confié toute une série
d'animations dans ces centres de loisirs
ainsi début juin la ville est en
préambule au bicentenaire de la
révolution
tom reconstituera plusieurs monuments
parisiens les boîtes capela qui
contiennent 200 pièces et sont vendus
165 francs sont en train de faire un
véritable boom sur le marché du jouet
pour faire face à l'avalanche des
demandes jusqu'à une chaîne de magasins
allemande qui vient de commander une
demie de boîte
tom van der bruggen est en train avec
l'appui des collectivités locales de
construire sur le plateau à lédergues un
nouvel atelier qui devrait démarrer le
mois prochain
[Musique]